once upon a time in a faraway land
there was a tiny kingdom tales as old as
time have a darker history than you
might think
the origins of disney's biggest hits
have some surprisingly macabre source
material
the source material for these disney
movies can be far more brutal
and they don't always have a happy
ending no
anna i belong here alone
when it comes to hans christian
andersen's the snow queen and frozen
disney changed more than the ending
elsa's inspiration
the snow queen was the villain the
heroine girda has to rescue her
childhood friend kai from her clutches
before his heart becomes completely
frozen gerda finds his cold body after
the snow queen abandons him
and weeps for her lost friend her warm
tears thawing his heart
and breaking the spell even the lovable
kristoff was based on the little robber
girl
an unpleasant and immoral character you
are not leaving this tower
ever tangled and earlier versions of
rapunzel
may start the same but tangled took a
left turn to send its characters on an
adventure
originally rapunzel is discovered by a
prince the two
falling in love he continues to secretly
visit her
until they are found out when rapunzel
becomes pregnant
enraged the witch cuts rapunzel's hair
and banishes her to the wilderness
and the prince jumps from the tower
landing in thorns that break his fall
but
blind him somehow they find each other
and rapunzel's tears heal his eyes
i am moana of motsu you didn't know that
one of the key elements of moana's plot
was based on true events
in the movie moana's people are
forbidden from traveling beyond
montenui's shores
a story thread lifted from a period of
polynesian history
known as the long pause according to
archaeological evidence
the islands of western polynesia were
settled around 800 bce
but the rest of polynesia stayed
seemingly untouched for at least another
1 000 years
the once seafaring people stopped
exploring for an entire millennium
and no one knows why you shouldn't have
to go
mulan there are plenty of young men to
fight for china
the original story of mulan dates back
to the northern way dynasty
over the centuries mulan's story has
been updated and adapted many times
in some versions mulan has to overcome
foot binding
breaking and tightly binding women's
feet to shrink and reshape them
this was a lifelong painful process but
an important symbol of status and beauty
in china from the 10th century until it
was banned in 1912.
the ending of mulan's tale varies wildly
with some of the darker retellings
concluding when she takes her own life
for honor
or out of defiance to foreign conquerors
i'm 16 years old i'm not a child don't
you take that
voice with me young lady hans christian
andersen's the little mermaid is a
tragic tale of unrequited love
ariel trades her voice for legs but it
comes with two stipulations
every step will be extremely painful and
if eric doesn't fall in love with her in
three days
she will die everything goes well until
eric is introduced to a princess
completely forgetting about ariel she is
given a chance to save herself by
sacrificing eric
she refuses and accepts her fate turning
into seafoam as the sun rises
the truth is i i sometimes dress as a
commoner
in the original 1001 nights the tale of
aladdin is far more complicated
aladdin falls in love with the princess
just before she is married to the
vizier's son
using the genie he sabotages the
marriage by teleporting the husband out
of bed every night taking his place
he lays a sword between them an old
tradition that meant he wouldn't do
anything
improper eventually the marriage is
annulled
and aladdin swoops in later the brother
of the sorcerer that tried to kill
aladdin for the lamp
shows up and aladdin stabs him in the
heart
now hold still this might sting a little
in older versions of beauty and the
beast adam is far
less deserving of a curse the witch
comes to his door when he's only a child
and he does what any of us would do
refuses to let a stranger in the house
while his parents aren't home
he is then cursed to become the beast
holding bell
the original story was a metaphor for
the isolation of women trapped in
arranged marriages so she doesn't even
have the furniture servants to keep her
company
at least it ends happily the two
breaking the curse and getting married
my name is pocahontas
disney's pocahontas has been heavily
criticized for its historical
inaccuracies
pocahontas was only 10 when she met john
smith
and never romantically involved at 16
pocahontas was taken hostage by
colonists then converted to christianity
and married becoming rebecca rolfe
whether she did so willingly is up for
debate
she died at only 20 but spent her life
advocating for her people
her real name wasn't even pocahontas it
was matuaka
which translates to flower between two
streams
just as she spent her life between two
worlds you must be
your fairy godmother of course
older tellings of cinderella are a lot
more bloody
in the grimms the wicked stepsisters are
so desperate to fit into the tiny
slipper and marry the prince
that they cut off pieces of their feet
but the prince spots their bleeding and
isn't fooled
as if that wasn't bad enough cinderella
has white doves from her late mother
instead of a fairy godmother
and they peck out the steph's sister's
eyes at her wedding
oh how silly of me i'm snow white
snow white is surprisingly sadistic in
the older tellings of her tail
the prince finds snow white under the
poison apple spell
and falls in love forcing his servants
to carry her around in a heavy glass
coffin
frustrated the servants slap her
dislodging the apple from her throat and
waking her up
snow white marries the prince inviting
her wicked stepmother to the wedding
upon her arrival snow white has her
forced into a pair of scolding hot iron
shoes making her dance until she dies
simba everybody knows about that really
oh yeah plenty of people have pointed
out the parallels between the lion king
and hamlet
but we're glad disney didn't copy
shakespeare's ending
hamlet is a tragedy and nearly every
character dies by the end because of
hamlet's quest for revenge
simba probably had a happier ending
because he had positive influences like
rafiki to guide him
that and his dad's ghost was more
concerned with simba being true to
himself
than avenging his death
right from your toes how's that while
both versions of disney's the jungle
book end on an uplifting note
maugley's story has a far more
bittersweet conclusion in rudyard
kipling's book
maugley is able to defeat sher khan with
the help of his animal friends
but when the man village finds out he
can communicate with animals
they accuse him of using magic and kick
him out he brings shur khan's pelt to
the wolf pack that originally raised him
and rejects their request to become
their leader feeling that he has nowhere
to truly belong
so what now i reckon you want a kiss
kissing would be nice yeah disney's the
princess and the frog
only shares a central premise with the
frog prince
in the fairy tale a princess is coerced
into inviting a pushy frog
into her home her father wants to teach
her a lesson in manners and keeping her
word
and forces her to go along with every
annoying invasive request the frog makes
eventually she reaches her limit and
throws the frog against the wall in rage
for some reason instead of killing him
this turns him back into a handsome
prince
seriously there isn't even a kiss sir
i'll have to ask you to release that
young keep moving junior
lady disney's hercules did an admirable
job of summarizing the many myths of
hercules
while still making the story their own
the hercules of myth was a far
more problematic guy than the lovable
zero to hero of the movie
in the midst megura is given to him as a
spoil of war
meaning she had little choice in
marrying him and starting a family
together
to make matters worse hera is spiteful
towards hercules for being the product
of one of zeus's many
many affairs and curses him with madness
just long enough for him to kill his
family in a rage
i am a monster you know he told you that
look at me
even though the hunchback of notre dame
is considered one of disney's darkest
movies
it doesn't hold a candle to victor
hugo's original novel
quasimodo is deaf and mute on top of his
deformities
phoebus is a heartless womanizer and
frallow is somewhat morally gray instead
of downright evil
the story comes to a climax when
esmerelda is framed for murdering
phoebus
who frallow stabbed in a jealous rage
when he saw them together
phoebus actually survives but does
nothing to save esmerelda from her death
sentence
frallow is pushed to fall to his death
by quasimodo
distraught over esmeralda's execution
which disturbing original version of a
disney classic shocked you the most
we would love to see you discuss in the
comments don't forget to leave us a like
if you learned something new
and subscribe for more awesome content